[Music]
Taron I want you to do well I want you
to have a great life
I love you but we cannot see a way that
you can live onto this roof
if we're gonna fundamentally go against
the grain of our beliefs
Cherith tell me the truth that's all I
think about men I don't know why I'm so
sorry your parents signed you up for a
program to fix you but here you are a
perfectly normal very healthy teenage
boy they're gonna do things for you if
you want to say welcome to the refuge
program from you cannot be born a
homosexual this is alive it's your
choice go fake it till you make it
become the man you are not save yourself
okay God will not love you the way that
you are this is what you want who's
gonna start this demon down
[Music]
I'm having a tough time I'm gonna give
you some advice tell them whatever they
want to hear
play the part unless it really think you
can change or anything I want to what
you going through right now is just a
moment unknown yeah a moment I love God
and I love my son for your father it's a
little more complicated we are not
finished I am because you won't listen
your father is sitting here telling how
you hate him
I'm not gonna pretend I hate my father I
don't hate my father
then where is all this anger come
because you're making me angry
they say sometimes you gotta hurt a
child in order to help them but a mother
knows when something is awry
I don't want to pretend anymore I've had
to ask myself and God if I'm ready to
lose you
you're ever
won't you never
[Music]
you